that's what's wrong right now everybody
trying to wrap the same style with the
uh i don't know who created it if it was
future or amigos but all of them [ __ ]
sound the same
look they get to get the tickets
i said [ __ ] had me in the studio one
night trying to do that [ __ ] i'm like
man cut this [ __ ] off
[ __ ] mine here doing [ __ ] i don't
rap like that i have a body who dropped
out of university because he wanted to
be a rapper and i was like you know you
could do both of those things
like i don't know how much this
sociology degree is interfering with
your rap career
where you're like we at school rap
something's got to give
how much rapping are you possibly doing
you're like hey four hours of class a
week no time philosophies hypocrisy
and you'd always post statuses you'd be
like everyone told me i couldn't be a
rapper it was like no one told you that
zero people cared you're like i don't
want to be a rapper everyone's like cool
you still owe me 20 bucks like that
hasn't changed
so whatever this week disney released a
new cd
featuring a rapping mickey mouse to
avoid controversy the cd will not
include the controversial hit single
cat killer
then there's some other [ __ ] they
pimping on our kids man
this gangster rap [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
we losing too many good brothers over
some [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know saying i work with tupac and
biggie
both of them good young brothers you
know what i'm saying lost in some
craziness
gangster rap ain't no such thing as a
[ __ ] gangster rapper
the two don't go together it's a
oxymoron
the first code of being a gangster is
what silence
if you're a rapper you talk too god damn
much
homeboy you never shut down
you're saying you telling all the damn
business in the damn song
had to drop a [ __ ] with my line as they
put him in the chalk line me mookie earl
your name dropping [ __ ]
now we got to kill your ass
you know saying real gangsters don't go
platinum
you'll never see john gotti come and
pick up a damn grammy
you know i'm saying scarface will never
accept an american music award
you know i'd like to thank uh first i'd
like to thank the [ __ ] uh director
what the [ __ ] is your name over there
huh what the [ __ ] is your name over
there huh
and say hello to my little friend i
still standing beat that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
now he's hollering west side
east side was shy
[ __ ] dying over a block they don't
even own
[ __ ] you're written
you paying rent [ __ ] you're saying
we're
going what's right if anybody should be
screaming west i should be some old
jewish dude
that's right
[Applause]
all right what do you think's overrated
right now
uh this this topic no
no no no what i think is overrated right
now
um hip-hop
really yeah like
the not having any words in your song
and it being
uh quote-unquote a classic or a hot
uh song for this time and then but 10
years down the road this guy said
nothing it was just
beating sounds oh it's just beating
it's like mumble rap like they don't
they don't say anything oh everybody
yeah everybody sounds like they're kind
of like half in the back
yeah and there's no originality anymore
but people
are still celebrating something that is
less original than it used to be
do you know how old you sound right now
the people in your generation says
gangster rapping there but originality
is not old that's that's true arrests
universal and they don't have any
weapons
when they're so unoriginal that their
name's not even different how many
little rappers do we have
little this little that little you can't
even name yourself an original name
all right when did they lose when did
hip-hop lose you
um uh probably the mid-2000s no
late 2000s like 2000 uh like maybe
11 2011 on and up but not all
you hung in there yeah but not all
hip-hop nights yeah you got artists like
eminem and naz who's still doing what
they're supposed to do god
you're doing like that's like me going
you know zeppelin and ac dc yeah they're
going back like 20 years
but those guys are still rapping those
guys are still relating and they're
still relevant
and it's the words like you got you
can't have a song with
it's instrumental what about the who
who's they got all the awards migos
the meek is it the migos i don't even
know him in don't listen to him
i don't even know i heard of him but i
don't know i know a lot of rapper's name
got
little in it and that bugs me
little uzi vert [ __ ] just change your
name to his original name
lil wayne was first and then everybody
else is a little
bit my tupac and biggie they had their
own names not his original name
yeah he went he went little because
there was already a too short
who is who is the uh the little person
there and uh
uh that [ __ ] god what was that
[ __ ] i don't know anybody
there was a guy bushwick bill bush yeah
he was
no he didn't even say little no he was
bushwicked he said where he was from
well you know these millennials are
[Applause]
[Music]
sensitive
[ __ ] i'm back matter of fact [ __ ]
i rap droppers on these bars ready to
attack
[ __ ] a whole [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm rap
[Music]
yeah matter of fact i'm going back and
forth look at me
[ __ ] i'm back and forth oh [ __ ]
hold on man fire hold on yo
i spit rocks like hot tops and bottle
rockets
come back [ __ ] i'm a pop market yeah
that's what that mean i'ma come back and
tell you [ __ ] say it in green
i'm real empty i am
do you like that ridge do you like that
ridge
i have a beat prepared do you wanna
really oh yeah you do yeah here we go
wow yo ridge wallet
are you using an old leather wallet
just stop it jesse's smiling
faker liar get the new ridge
that [ __ ] is fire stop
talking about white genocide in south
africa
it might be an issue but i don't know
it also might be a hysteria
is it a bio weapon maybe but stop your
[ __ ]
schlepping and get a ridge wallet
911 didn't happen the towers are still
there
thank you in the building 150 kids
not children uh i'm going back home
look at me i'm not alone drop a beat a
realist [ __ ]
around you don't believe me hear my
sound [ __ ] beats go down
yeah check stick cause my lips get
chapped don't believe me [ __ ]
then write me back on my email
sent down a big blast you didn't respond
[ __ ]
you came last [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah at the
end of the day it's real rap
whoa one time i was hosting and there
was three guys i've never hosted how
many times have you
just one time it was a mistake did it
not go well it was all right did you do
update
no that's right it was really it was
right after i got fired from an update i
thought it'd be fun
there are three uh uh guys doing
music you know i don't know music i just
know old music
like again lauren would go who do you
like and i go you like the you know this
guy uh
uh bobby goldsmith
[Laughter]
except me it was snoop dogg he just
changed his name and he was angry
because i kept getting it wrong
he used to be snoop doggy dog the snoop
dogg at eminem and dr dre
so it's a pretty heavy lineup yeah but
to me it was two black guys
francis farmer they were about to go up
and take me with him they were standing
in their rap positions as you know like
against and i'm about to introduce them
so they're standing in that rap position
where it looks like
they'll either start singing rap or pull
a gun and
kill you so uh so then i go
as a joke i look at them because i
remember this is kind of a lettermany
thing to do but i go fellas are you
ready are you ready
which forces them to go like shake their
heads slightly
even though they're in this crazy day
so i thought that was funny but then i
learned later they were geniuses and i
should have befriended them